yeah they're headed to the secret portal
and then here they've figured out
yet another way to spell out mortal
kombat
backwards backwards all our combat is
backwards yeah
kind of yeah and how do we
code our tournament how do we hide our
tournament amongst regular people
i got it put some letters backwards
all of them but the r leave the r
forward because
corn owns the backwards r exclusive once
we get to the allen mortal put it
backwards
backwards
what's going on reject nation so i saw a
lot of comments saying we gotta check
this video out because
it's another video from warner brothers
hbo max same day premieres and we're
going to be getting extended first looks
at
movies like mortal kombat the suicide
squad etc let's just hop into it then
after
we check out the trailer we'll go
through this shot by shot give
our breakdown our instantaneous
breakdown let's do this
all you have to do is follow my voice
so this is the famous suicide squad damn
that looks
great that looks so good even getting me
excited for joel kinnaman
we got actual dialogue venus and serena
go shake up this world
what was that movie must have been in
the heights
the streets i'm so excited for this
movie
i've heard about that reminiscence
of the k was backwards there yeah
unless what they're showing off is dope
john
whoa that was cool was sub-zero
like uh what was he doing that we got
right behind the back
raising hail
damn and still no matrix
still no matrix oh we still get we got
to get some official trailers for this
that looks great let's uh let's break
this down
before we go to the beginning let's just
try to find that
there it is it's a sub-zero moment i
want to just slow this down really quick
because that was the most appealing shot
of the trailer to me
okay so is he like is he turning rain
into ice and then raising that yeah like
like where is it like he's living on the
street or something
that's freaky
oh is he like the main villain of this
one are we gonna be like sympathizing
for scorpion because
we saw a moment there this does not look
like it's part of the tournament
out in an alleyway yeah this looks like
the mortal kombat short film that they
would make to promote their movie
it looks like it's in one of those small
towns that always has the misfortune of
being swallowed up in some kind of
supernatural event
that is a great ass looking moment
oh yeah he's that he must be doing that
taking the condensation converted
so he's got like shards of like stabbing
ice all around him
unless they put this shot backwards and
it really is just snowing
no no no no no and then this moment
right here
also okay the hanzo aka scorpion they
said
that the first 10 minutes would explore
his like bloody ass
violent origins yes so this is the
prologue
yeah this has to be the prologue within
the first i mean there's like so much
blood on that sword i know and on that
tree over there
which that's just the idea i think
that's just the iv but it would lead
into uh that fight with sub-zero with
the origins between their rivalries
it's this looks so cool and then right
here that beat shot that you kind of saw
a glimpse of in the other trailer but
it's more clear
you got johnny cage lou kang sonja
that's not johnny cage no that's kato uh
okay cato
lou kane sonia blade and
cole yeah yeah oh young everyone
sonia blade is like it's so easy to cast
on your blade i feel like
get a blonde model get a blonde model
replacement
a little bit and then there you go model
you put her in shape and you got
something you played right
pretty much as far surprised you don't
see jackson this shot right here
i'm surprised they're not putting him in
more in general because that arm looks
rad
so i take it in this beach shot they're
going they're headed to the tournament
yeah they're headed to the secret portal
and then here they figured out
yet another way to spell out mortal
kombat
backwards backwards all our combat is
backwards
yeah kind of yeah and how do we
how do we code our tournament how do we
hide our tournament amongst regular
people
i got it put some letters backwards
all of them but they are leave the r
forward because
corn owns the backwards r exclusive once
we get to the
alan mortal put it backwards backwards
no one will see it coming or going but
these shots of suicide squad
oh man they do look absolutely beautiful
i don't know what this rain void is but
yeah these shots alone just have such a
yeah just a splash page
picturesque quality even though they're
so simple like i mean
even just getting this chance to see
joel could have been like oh [ __ ] i'm
excited to see him i'm actually
excited just one snippet of a moment
maybe
go oh you know what i'm looking forward
to rick flack coming back now our part
of the squad buddy
sorry i gave you so much crap about june
moon the suicide squad moment straight
out of bad boys too
yeah i always think of bad boys too when
i see this sipping up a moment yeah
guns opportunity to really tribute the
man who inspired it all michael day
i like when you slow this down it looks
like she took out all these soldiers
who have assault rifles with these two
guns yeah man
she did it fantasy of every first person
shooter game can i get the game done
with just my ppk
all she did was circle around
just ran into certainly and she wanted
to take them all out didn't even look
when she was aiming
i love this back and forth here this
feels like such a james gun
a driven moment and a perfect john cena
moment and then
instantly has you going uh yep i think
john cena's type of
style and humor bodes perfectly with
james
oh yeah for james gunn this character
this universe like it seems like you
could just let him off the leash let's
try that again no one likes to show off
unless what they're showing off as dope
as [ __ ]
i mean he's got a point
let's put their shoulders maybe my
favorite moment
yeah vigilante polka dot man harley
quinn it's a cool shot though
dude like even it is a run with polka
dot man you're like
he's got a carrot like that they all
like what i love about this mode is they
all have their own kind of run
yeah it's like that's so specific to the
type of characters they
are yeah it really gets me excited to
see like how much each of these people
embodies these characters
even in the body language of their run
you could look at that you could just
pay attention to all three of them they
each have a different type of run
oh yeah so fun you got at a descending
scale of efficiency from left to right
then we got this shot right here what is
this godzilla versus kong
it's time jerry it's tom and jerry
you completely submerged in new york oh
yeah this is god's
godzilla godzilla versus because the
whole city is in ruins
oh my god look at that flooding
situation they have going on that is a
scary ass shot
this moment i didn't realize it when we
first initially watched the other
trailer
but they're actually making a tony
soprano movie
like an origin movie i think alan
taylor's directing it i think so yeah
and see where tony fell into the vat of
pasta sauce that turned him into a
monster
maybe like a spiderman movie
what i'm here for guys i'm a big
sopranos fan i really love that
i really really love the hell out of
that series as difficult as it is to
replace james gandolfini there's a lot
of episodes in that series that do
flashbacks that
don't have m in there there's people
playing young tony soprano i think there
might be some backlash of the fact that
they're doing this at the same time
though if you remember the series
whenever they did flashbacks it wasn't
james gandolfini
i think like almost every time it wasn't
him
you know so seeing a younger version of
him watching how he grew up into this
life
and will really let him down here
because there are some in between stuff
you can explore so i'm really excited
for that i'm gonna watch it having never
seen the show
it's the same moment that they have a
space jam it says welcome to
the space champs you actually hear it
this time here's your chance
you know do your dance if you feel fine
i'm pretty sure this is a more
fleshed out there's a bigger crowd here
more stuff there's a crowd happening
here if you remember
i remember the other one it didn't look
this pack
it's the same sequence it's the same
zipping up shot
but there's definitely a lot more people
in this shot than before it's like a
huge crowd
yeah and there are a couple like huge
characters that aren't king kong as well
yeah
does that say first quarter okay so this
is like right is the game it's about the
first game yeah
this is from those who wish me dead the
taylor sheridan movie
a movie which title i keep forgetting
will probably be the only oscar
contender on this whole list
the conjuring three the devil made me do
it uh i like that they're in the saw
bathroom in this
yeah right the first thing i bought them
like come on cross them over james juan
multiverse
do you even love it about the this
conjuring footage they don't lead with
like
anything scary no it's just it's just
the end of the rainbow and looking
miserable
they're together they're together and
they look anguish
that's the soul of these movies and then
for everyone who was confused by what
this will smith movie is
no it's not seven pounds two this is uh
king rich
are we gonna get eight pounds the the
finally we're getting the venus and
serena williams story
starring will smithfest focus on the
and it's fascinating because there's a
that selena series that came out and i
heard so much of the focus was on the
father specifically and he kind of felt
like it was more about him and selena
maybe there's a thread in
in very successful performers and
athletes lives were just like a really
hard ass yes
give you a lot of baggage but will make
you the best
man i love will smith he is either
insanely charismatic
or just super duper dramatic
super vulnerable like on the virginity
where is the middle ground
he's after one of the two man bagger
vance
that's the middle like i thought like
pursuit of happiness i thought he had a
great middle ground of charisma and
heavy trauma and then
after that it's like he's either going
to go so dramatically but where is he
super fun i want him to make a richard
link later movie because then we will
see
chill smith this is reminiscence i
looked at the plot to this and it says a
scientist discovers a way to re-live
your past and use this technology to
search
for his long-lost love which is
fascinating to me because
that kind of reminds me of the fountain
it's different but the internal
fountain of the spotless hue you know
like time travel different times in life
and then
it's all about trying to reconnect with
your though your past love it's a
fascinating
fascinating thing to explore you were
saying this is in the heights yeah
that's gotta be in the heights yeah
okay and in the heights unless suicide
squad has some kind of coordinated
i could honestly when this flash when
this moment flashed by in a super super
duper quick moment it looked like a
horror movie yeah
yeah like is this the conjuring is the
suicide squad which one is it
malignant when you slow it down you're
like oh that's definitely a musical
number
yeah you know what i know this trailer
really threw down on in the heights
and i feel like this would be a good
opportunity for them to be like
oh disney plus you may have hamilton but
we got it yeah
exactly exactly and you got this shot
here which almost looks like a mob movie
this feels like a mob shot movie so i'm
assuming this is the tony surprise yeah
there's a dead guy in the background is
it the oh oh yeah right here there's a
dead dude right here
just the way they're all dressed this
looks like a period piece around the
time when tony soprano
and especially the colors yeah it's like
yeah it's very designed
to be evocative clint eastwood western
movie that got made because warner
brothers likes to be friends with clint
eastwood but no one's really going to
watch this movie
you know clint eastwood is like
religious movies he's got a solid base
of people who always turn out and that's
all you need to finance
this looks like yeah this is a streaming
movie here
all right guys so much out this is
exciting i'm really happy we got to
check this out which one exci
outside of godzilla which one excites
you the most leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that notification
bell hit that like button we'll catch
you guys soon